[Music]
oh this looks bright it's a wholesome
family
can i play this wholesome family please
this is a family yes
you know that you have a sex doll in
your lounge with your 17 year old we
sell sex dolls they can come in all
shapes and sizes you've got four
children if somebody said that it's a
business that children shouldn't be
around then i would say that they do not
understand the business i feel like
there's a lot of
for instance
i feel like children shouldn't really be
around any business when they're
children just let them be children right
i mean
even if you just took your kids to a
[ __ ] you know an
upholstery place or [ __ ] whatever you
just wouldn't want to bring kids there
why do you have to have the dolls at
home
well it's a home
business eldest son harry is coming on
board to do the digital marketing for
the business this is the first time
really that harry is going to be
properly around a doll what
huh family businesses you love to see it
hey england what happened to you you'd
love to see it what happened to you
england
what kind of positions do you think we
should put around or thought
come on
all right fellas
so they just buy and resell sex dolls
yes
that's not really
a business well they take care of the
shipping part
easiest
are they
never
hold the door pretty soon
that's it this one's not a particularly
heavy one but because it's not a
particularly big one this one's probably
about 35 kilos i would say they have to
be heavy to be able to have the weight
behind it for the purpose of their
intended look man i don't give a [ __ ] if
you want to make sex though that's your
prerogative why are you why is this a
family business
and again doesn't seem to be
it's not like
there are craftsmen and the kids are
learning the craft right they're just
getting them shipped to them and then
marking them up and reselling them on
ebay
seems a bit [ __ ] weird a weird fleet
the idea was born um
out of reading an article about sex
dolls it pricked our imagination really
you know excuse the pun yeah we just
explored it from there and then next
thing you know
so you bought a sextile and you used a
sex doll like let's start glaze over can
we not gloss over that because they just
kind of they were like hey it's just
something we read an article about and
then we you know we uh so we looked into
it more so you
you bought and [ __ ] the sex doll so he
says just don't leave that part out
born it's not every day you know that
you have a sex doll in your lounge with
your 17 year old
no i mean it's not any day for most
people it's not any day you know what
the real crime is that fade
yeah well that's they're british they're
very unfortunate people when it comes to
looks we are obviously very aware that
there is a stigma attached to you know
what we do why would there be
it's a wholesome profession
but that's really from people who are
quite small-minded it's just a business
that's all it is yeah somebody i could
put in the chat they go you know they
just bought it for themselves and they
made made an excuse and now they started
the whole business out of the excuse no
no we we import sex dolls
just tell me import sex tools and they
keep up the charade forever
running this business that just keeps
hemorrhaging money
do you think they buy them and then use
them and then sell them
that's gross i probably do
you know and oh this one comes
pre-lubricated nice
you you brought it up you brought it up
a sun you buddy
you know we're glad that we took care
we're taking away the stigma from it no
you haven't you're not how does this how
does this take away the stigma
it's like when gay guys are like do they
do these like same special interest
piece and they're like that's why we
that's why when we go to like the cubs
game we suck each other's dicks right
there at the gate entrance while
everybody's walking by because we're
trying to remove the stigma you should
remove it i don't think that you're
helping yeah completely i know imagine
going to a cubs game
that's like removing the stigma of going
to a cubs game
no we were just going to suck each
other's dicks and we wanted a place
where there wasn't a lot of people
around
so they go to a cubs game
oh [ __ ]
it's not seedy we sell it it's not sadie
at all whereas it's very serious very
serious literally you put your seat in
it you're [ __ ] a lifeless not even a
realistic depiction of a human being a
literal doll
yeah for that just [ __ ] have sex with
an asian sex worker uh-huh yeah
seriously
other people might be selling this
product who wouldn't rather just have
sex with like some ugly chick
than a fake doll
cd so i think that is where we differ
from the other sex doll companies
this is our home life is very busy we've
got a really happy family haven't we
we've got four children we've got harry
who's 17. then louie he's 14. sonny who
is eight yeah i know i know the [ __ ]
uh
what was it was a group called
was that british boy band that was hot
for a while i forgot one direction one
direction yeah yeah i've seen one
direction before i know your kids he's
four
as we get older we would hope that maybe
naturally our children would want to
take control of the business
yeah because that's
why yeah
why why not let them just why
when my parents first told me i didn't
believe it at first it was weird then i
come in all of them
i come in all the sextiles
i'm acknowledging that it was weird and
at my initial my initial
uh
reaction yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
visual reaction was that this is wrong
but now it's cool because my parents
just say it's cool and they give buy me
whatever i want so it's cool now so i'm
gonna grow up with really twisted ideas
of
uh sex and and
i'm probably gonna become a [ __ ]
serial killer
it's not a sex doll it's a sex action
figure watch the old generation of
serial killers that are going to be like
i don't know about my parents had a sex
doll i grew up i grew up viewing women
as empty [ __ ]
empty [ __ ] soulless objects that you
stick your dick in that stare off into
space so i wanted to make all the women
i was with more like the dolls yeah i
mean like there's gonna be a lot of
these kids growing up all [ __ ] up the
dolls never judged me
i'll make them all into dolls they all
loved me it's literally gonna be an
interview there's gonna be a [ __ ]
jcs [ __ ] uh video on youtube and a
couple years of some kid going like oh
no i just wanted to make them all like
the dolls this guy this father is making
a christopher nolan batman villain
like this is his origin story dull man
can i get used to it really and the most
common question i'll be asked every time
is are you in the proud boys and
probably
like that is true someone brought it up
in the chat one of the kids names is
dolly
oh i didn't catch that one of the kid's
name is dolly
that's gross
no i don't need frozen we're going to be
buying you a sex doll we need you to
test it out and see how it works okay
nope
why
oh you don't worry it's going to be
discreet shipping we're going to put
stickers on it goes this is definitely
totally not a sex doll
there you go now you have a co-host for
sunday night [ __ ] shows and spent left
it was always oh you have one can you
give me one can i have a discount why
younger children they don't really ask
do they
because they're embarrassed too
yeah just like dolly's gonna be
embarrassed when she doesn't tell
everybody how she got her name mm-hmm
mm-hmm while she's waiting to go on
stage at a strip club
i mean
where'd you get the name dolly uh my mom
is a huge dollar partner yeah that's
just what it was just you just got it
right you have to go with something like
that
i was like still in our home i don't
think they recognise really what the
product is so i just think they're a bit
too young to be taking on board at the
moment and you don't see that as a
problem
you don't see that as an issue
if somebody said that it's a business
that children shouldn't be around
then i would say that they do not
understand the business
okay i think i understand the business
so and please some because i want to see
because i don't think children should be
around
import export of sex dolls so you're
importing and exporting things that
people come inside of
but not even things like
not even like things people come inside
right because who cares right i mean you
could technically
indict every company that makes socks
true you really want to go that route
with it but it's more
the fact that they're
humanoid-shaped
but very lifeless doll like
objects that frankly only serial killers
should be able to come in i think is
more the problem right because it's like
i don't need a fleshlight i don't need
any wacky [ __ ] all i need is a little
lotion five minutes of my own time
privately somewhere to get the job and
sometimes not even the lotion right
sometimes you gotta just make do
other than that i don't understand this
like
what do you undress them and then you're
like i don't want i don't want to
comment anything that quint from jaws
has a speech about
no [ __ ] thank you it just see it's
it seems like you'd have to be a [ __ ]
sociopath
to [ __ ] uh you know whatever by the
way [ __ ] you said only five minutes
marsh if it takes you more than five
minutes to jack off then you're you're
wasting your day what are you doing let
me ask you something do you take longer
to jerk off because it's so fun like is
it it's not hey [ __ ] it's not sex yes
sex you're gonna try to hold it together
because you're having fun who the [ __ ]
has ever been jerking off and has been
like i'm enjoying myself
i'm gonna stay here for 20 minutes
it's like no bing bang bong let's go
[ __ ] wash your hands go back to whatever
you were doing
um at all or how we operate the business
or how we operate the business yeah any
kind of judgment is of no consequence to
us because it is ill-informed
i feel pretty informed
i don't think this is like they're not
making some sort of new element or
chemical compound that i wouldn't
understand scientifically
i know what you do i am very well
informed you sell things for people to
[ __ ] i got it
we are more than happy with how we
provide for our family which is
the reason why we do it isn't it correct
have you got anything to say to the
haters
[ __ ] haters man
he's about to be edgy dude all right
let's go to the philly crew how do you
like your sex dolls
trucker
coming up in a little bit we're gonna
have colin kane in the studio merchant i
do that to each other all the time for
no reason just be like billy cruz
[ __ ]
yeah we do honestly i would have to say
ironically enough i think that me and
royce because we barely talk about opie
on the air
but we probably quote opie more off the
air
it's just god why
i'm over it why are they high why did
they not get i don't get them over it
[ __ ] haters man
have you got anything to say to the
haters
ah he's edgy
you're british sir i'll kill you with my
bare hands
and if not with my gun because i'm
american
look how many followers they have like
they're making it seem like this is a
huge business
but free worldwide shipping royce oh
good
to expand our social media content isn't
that and obviously the way that the
world is now we recognize they're good
vehicles to bring harry on board was
just a natural thing to happen wasn't it
to help do that
harry's wanted to pursue a career in
digital marketing anyway obviously it
was a natural fit so today we're going
to go over to the studio
and we're going to do a little photo
shoot we are with another one of the new
dolls of course they have a range rover
of course of course they also have the
shittiest
luxury truck you can buy website today
is the first time i'll be actually going
to the studio and do some social media
marketing and just learning about like
the environment and getting used to like
the cameras and
your parents [ __ ] those everything
[Music]
the branding of the products is so
important you know what's really sexy
too on a woman is
is that real that deep ridge that goes
fully around their neck where their head
screws on yeah that's my favorite that's
the most realistic part right it's super
hot
it's just like
they're literal dolls you're just
[ __ ] a giant doll all right
set your minutes i like to do these
photo shoots lots of other sex style
companies they do tend to just use the
same stock photos over and over and over
again so but i need something to have my
child involved in this this is
definitely unique
i think that we're probably best now to
put in a different position okay so what
position would you like okay how would
you do something what do you think
or false yeah
all fours does that do you really want
to hear
imagine you want to hear your kid
telling you to put a sex doll on all
fours and then they go man i wonder why
people think we're weird
yeah it's um
sex is getting
really weird
you know
it's just everybody is so [ __ ] up now
and i know this was their plan all along
but they've succeeded everyone is so
[ __ ] up now even porn dude when you go
to like a porn site now
just everything is stepsister
aunt
you know what i mean uncle and you're
like what is that why why i don't need
this
like come on come on x-tube you should
know i like i like a black chick with a
big booty light skin to answer your
question why is it that when you go to
porn sites have an answer
[Music]
really is the pornhub [ __ ] theme song
yeah i actually said i asked uh somebody
actually made that for me they made you
like the pornhub exclusive but they put
this song over that's hilarious
it's almost 10k views now yeah this
almost has ten thousand people i said i
wanted nine thousand by that time we got
back from vegas and ladies and gentlemen
you [ __ ] did it 9 600 views